don't get caught up with your
imagination to jump into it right away
your first tiny step will make this all
happen don't feel that you have to very
smart to do something stupid people like
us do things it works out because human
beings is not they are not always about
money human beings is much bigger than
just money making machine all human
beings in the world are entrepreneurs
that's in our DNA that's in our blood
she'll give her life to make sure that
Trust is kept we think making money is
the purpose of the life purpose of life
is not making money when you imagine
don't put a limit be as wide as you can
be well the thing that I see about the
world what it should be it's all
question of imagination
he's a Bangladeshi social entrepreneur
banker an economist he was awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize for pioneering the
concepts of microcredit and micro
financing he also serves on the board of
directors of the United Nations
Foundation he's Muhammad Yunus and
here's my take on his top 10 rules for
success imagine big things but always
this is my recommendation personally
always start very small as small as you
can get don't get caught up with your
imagination to jump into it right away
your first tiny step will make this all
happen so limit yourself into tiny
little thing of change and make that
happen it's easy it's not difficult if
you make very simple very easy you don't
get a scare if you don't know something
don't feel that you have to very smart
to do something stupid people like us do
things it works out
so that's a fun part of it don't feel
scared about challenging things
conventional bankers always telling me
we don't learn we can't lend money to
the poor people you know why because
they are not credit worthy
I have heard of millions of times
telling me that they are not credit
worthy I wondered should the banks tell
people whether they are credit worthy or
not
oh that people should be telling the
banks whether their people were there
not you refer you reverse the whole
question then you get it so doing the
opposite way doing the stupid way it's
not a bad thing everything that we do in
the business world is focused on making
money that's what indicate indicator
that you try to assess how successful we
are in the business world there's
nothing else so that kind of squeezed
out all kinds of social orientation of
human life and human activity and that's
not a tenable situation and that
untenable situation is created by the
structure that we have that business
doesn't have to be always money centered
always self centered always or many
times obsessed with money because human
beings is not they are not always about
money human beings is much bigger than
just money making machine we are not
robots we are human beings we take care
of ourselves individually at the same
time we take care of everybody else we
take care of the planet itself and
business world doesn't have that
orientation so at the moment we can do
that we can create a different kind of
business which is not money center the
designing of education system is very
important it's not I tell again this is
also relevant for education system I
tell that you don't have to wait to
finally graduate finally get your
master's degree or whatever degree to
get it to become an interpreter you can
become intrapreneur anytime you want in
any class you are aiming for the junior
high school or senior class it doesn't
matter good year in interpreter you
don't wait for certain
figured you wait for a certificate when
you will look for a job because you need
this piece of paper to get in this is
your entry document to get in but
entrepreneur doesn't need it that
doesn't mean that you don't need
education you need education to the
extent that you are interested in not
because of a certificate so certificate
orientation can go if you are an
entrepreneur and make sure what are the
things interest you and get through
those kind of education so who told you
to have jobs
did your teacher tell you to have jobs
did you read it in your textbooks of
course they cannot answer that question
I said forget about jobs job is a very
old-fashioned idea
obsolete idea that should have ended in
the last century but somehow it's nicked
in get rid of it you keep telling
yourself again and again I'm not a job
seeker I'm a job creator and behave like
a job creator think like a job creator
certainly you see completely different
thing emerging in front of you it's in
your head which caused the problem not
in your ability you have the ability to
become intrapreneur and I tell them that
all human beings in the world are
entrepreneurs that's in our DNA that's
in our blood that's how millions of
years we lived in this planet by using
that entrepreneurship when we're in the
caves we are not sending job
applications from job from table number
five to cave number fifteen do you have
a job for me
we carried the tradition of go-getters
we are go getters we are problem solvers
some people mistaken it converted into
job seekers as if human beings are not
born to work for somebody else human
being is much bigger than that but the
moment you accept a job you limit
yourself your life is made into tiny
little thing which were yourself is huge
big thing your creative power can go any
direction you want
that's what you should be who have you
seen as an inspirational figure
well I'm sure many people probably in
early stage when I was growing up I
would say my mother was my inspiration
because she didn't go to school to study
very much here's a fourth grade fifth
grade probably that's all about
education yet but a very unique
character very open very helping papers
and she always inspired me on that
whatever it is she did the other one the
inspiration I get from the people that I
work with all these women that work in
the village they how hard their life is
and how they worked so hard to make a
little difference in their life to make
sure their children don't have to go to
the misery that she has gone through
that's the only thing she does and she's
so committed given this tiny money she
gets in her hand she tries to get the
best mileage out of this money when she
received this first money when you give
her loan from Grameen Bank as I said the
initial loan will be about $30 or $35
when she holds this money she literally
shakes she can understand it still
because she cannot believe anybody could
trust her with such an enormous amount
of money she thinks this is such a huge
money she doesn't know what how to
handle this money so that's what the
shaking part comes and the inside of our
key she keeps promising anybody who has
trusted her all this money didn't ask
for anything just gave her the money on
the basis of the trust she will give her
life to make sure that Trust is kept and
her I shall be tears will be running
down from her eyes not believing that
this wheel is it's not a dream as a real
time in the rest of her life she
struggles to make sure she makes that
thing true that yes he her trust will
never be broken and that's what keeps
the whole Grameen Bank microcredit
together the relationship of trust
between the two we think making money is
the purpose of the life purpose of life
is not making
purpose of life is to make oneself happy
and the rest of the world happy but that
purpose is forgotten so we have to read
we invent the purpose what is the
purpose of our life that's what the
young people looking for human life is
about creativity about doing things so
that it becomes a legacy you really
build a legacy for yourself that's not
what we do in business we in business we
have a big stack of cash and that's why
I might say goodbye we have the capacity
to chase that thing nobody should be
unemployed nobody should be poor for the
same reason we are capable nobody should
be wealthy are dependent imagination is
the real power imagine like I imagined
about the app to transport me into your
side all the crazy things that you can
think about when you imagine don't put a
limit be as wide as you can be in
creating the image of the world that you
want to create without any hesitation
without any limitation be as wild as it
can be in your imagination as if you are
writing a social fiction we write
science fiction all the time but
unfortunately we don't write social
factions fictions of the driving force
like in science in technology science
fiction becomes a driving force it makes
things happen similarly if you have done
the social friction it will make it
happen let's imagine that I was one of
Grameen banks clients and I have a loan
but what mindset do I need for myself to
succeed well succeed did you take a loan
to start a business that's what you
explained to the bank that this is what
I will do and you focus on that that I
have to be successful in this and make
sure that I can be I can pay back all
the money out of the income that I make
out of the investment that I did and
that's the focus is very important in
self-confidence then I can do it because
many of borrowers may be like you never
had an experience before taking money
from
somebody else and doing things and
paying man they never handled money in
many cases because their husbands
handled the money for the first time
they are handing money so they're scared
to death
so have confidence make it happen
squeeze step by step and then once you
have been successful in getting the
money back
you become very confident you did it
because you got through the whole
process came out successful that builds
up tremendous amount of success well the
thing that I see about the world what it
should be it's all question of
imagination
you
if we imagine today what kind of world
we want and that's the world would be
created everybody has a freedom to
imagine in his or her way my imagination
is we want to create a world which will
be absolutely free from poverty meaning
that there will be no poor person on
this planet anywhere in the world and
once we create that will create poverty
museums so the people who would like to
know what is it abuse to be called
poverty how did it happen
so they will go into poverty Museum they
take their children to poverty museum
that's the kind of world we were I would
like to build and that will be the world
where there will be no unemployment and
when you tell people or they used to
unemployment there's a big crisis if
there's a lot of unemployed people the
young unemployed then people may wonder
what is unemployment why should anybody
be unemployed they have capacity why one
a human being should be unemployed what
does it mean they will be writing thesis
to understand what is unemployment why
did it happen in those past this and
nobody should be on welfare why state
has to take care of people or any
charity organization has to take care of
people because human being has
everything inside how come we couldn't
provide the facility so that you can
bring those physical capacities and
contribute to the world and we would
want to create a world where it will be
no unnecessary deaths
we pride our technology we pride our
knowledge simple thing why human being
die preventable diseases those diseases
should be gone so that's the kind of
world in a world where we will not make
this planet more dangerous than it was
before
we'll make it every day it will be more
safe than it was yesterday so we start
thinking about it and we start working
towards it and it will happen when we
create fiction social fictions it will
happen like we do science fiction's
we've got the moon that was a science
fiction they go to the Mars that was a
science fiction we go to another galaxy
that's a science fiction because we make
those fictions size follows them make it
happen in the science fiction there is
something that we start talking to each
other
if imagination can do it reality should
be able to do that too and it is
becoming more and more possible because
all the science and technology is in the
hands of us right now much more than any
any time ever in history why can't we
make things happen now what is our
excuse why should anybody be uneducated
on this planet is it because the cost
cost is gone science has made it
possible technology has made it possible
you don't have to just come to one
classroom the same time class can be
taught all over the world and every
single thing can ring up if we do not
imagine it will not be done if we
imagine some day it will happen
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because tell weed Rahman
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of
muhammad's top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon
like I explained to young people in
Bangladesh in a language that probably
they understand
I said why should you go for the job
because if you take a job you start at
the bottom nobody will give you a top
job when you first time you get so you
take orders from your immediate boss and
then there's a series of buses on top of
it so all your life is trying to satisfy
your boss all your creative power you're
sacrificing why should you sacrifice
your creative power I said if you're
going to end enterpreneur pop you want
to become entrepreneurs start at the top
because you are the boss you are the one
who decide you create you bring all your
creative resources into the picture all
your creative capacity in the picture so
today we sacrifice ourselves that we
don't bring our creative power because
of the system of taking jobs